il est désormais difficile d'y échapper
la lecture numérique investi les
magasins depuis sa mise sur le marché en
mais les yvelinois ont encore du mal à
lire du virtuel je ne suis pas habituel
j'essaie de me forcer à m'habituer
mais 0 ça j'arrive pas moi quand je lis
mph du papier enfin bouquin il me plaît
c'est d'avoir l'objet en main et puis
j'aime l'odeur du papier et voilà donc
je retrouve pas dans ça dans les
tablettes même si je trouve ça très
intéressant de pouvoir stocker beaucoup
d'informations sur un seul objet léger
et portatif dans ce magasin des
clayes-sous-bois les liseuses de livres
numériques ont été mises en rayon il ya
quelques mois et les ventes ont déjà
décollé avec ses tablettes vous n'êtes
plus obligé de transporter votre
bibliothèque quand vous partez en
vacances
la liseuse pouvant stocker plusieurs
milliers d'ouvragés chez trois des
produits d'automatisme
selon un baromètre d'opinionway de
novembre 2012 le nombre d'électeurs en
france a plus que doublé en six mois et
représentent désormais 14% des 15 ans et
plus pourtant le marché français du
livre numérique estimé à 20 millions
d'euros est noyée dans les 4 milliards
d'euros de la forme papier
malgré des oeuvres moins coûteuse pour
les collecteurs pour obtenir vos livres
favoris il vous faudra débourser entre
80 et 150 euros